We're now streaming.
Hello,
and welcome back to the Rawkode Academy.
I'm your host, David Flanagan. Although you probably
know me as Rawkode from across the Internet.
Today, we have another wonderful episode of Rawkode
Live where we take a look at open
source software that helps to make your lives
easier and simpler in this cloud native landscape.
Today, we are taking a look at a
project called Helm Dashboard from a team at
Commodore. And to guide us through our journey
today, I'm joined by its creator and maintainer,
Andre.
Hello. Welcome. How are you?
Hello. Hi, everyone. I'm super happy to join.
My name is Andre, and you probably know
me by other open source projects that I've
been doing in the past. And these days,
I'm joining Commodore
as a company and leading open source development
in
Commodore.
Couple of words about Commodore. What what's the
company?
Commodore is producing
the solution for
easier troubleshooting and management
in
Kubernetes
and everything that relates to Kubernetes.
This is why
the project that we are looking on today
is also related to Kubernetes
and Helm.
And the project is Helm Dashboard.
Should I start the presentation?
Well, I'm curious. You said we may know
you from previous open source projects. Do wanna
tell us a little bit more about your
background there? What have you what have you
worked on?
Sure.
I
my open source journey was starting from the
load pasting area where I was doing tooling
around of a load pasting.
And
then I
open sourced couple of interesting tools
to do the either high scale load testing
or lower scale, but with more details about
around the visualization and analysis of the lower
testing results.
And so people inside the lower testing area
know me. At least everyone knows
the tools that I did, not necessarily
my person. Doesn't matter.
And from there, I I found that it's
actually exciting to start the projects and do
open source in many different areas.
For example, if you'll find my YouTube, you'll
find there the
robots
built from Lego and the software library that
is behind that, and that's the open source
written in Python or
some crazy experiments with chess and neural networks,
and it's also open source.
And some people who find it just have
fun because I was writing the
journaling all of my experience,
which I cannot say is fully
breakthrough,
but just the fun of the process of
making it and sharing it with people.
This is what excites me, and this is
what led me to hear, basically.
Alright. So I'm curious then. You said Lego
robots. You said chess and machine learning. You've
got a little of Python going on there.
How did you end up in this Kubernetes
landscape?
How
can you avoid Kubernetes
these days? I don't know. Regardless
of where you started in your past, you
will end up with Kubernetes today because it's
everywhere.
This is the huge wave of transformation
or at least adoption that comes
in
technology,
in infrastructure.
So anything that relates to Kubernetes will be
there for long these days. And
I
actually, several years, was looking at Kubernetes
thinking, how will I apply
myself to Kubernetes? What will I do in
Kubernetes? And thanks to Commodore, I'm now able
to actually
meaningfully
contribute to the ecosystem of Kubernetes.
So I'm I'm all excited about Kubernetes. I
like it.
Awesome. That's wonderful to hear. So the announcement
was this week, Commodore said in fact, was
it yesterday?
It's been such a weird week for me.
Yeah. I think it was yesterday Commodore
Helm Dashboard and this new project, and you're
gonna guide us through it today. So without
further ado, I'll say, why don't you share
your screen? We've got a few slides, and
then we'll take a look at the project
hands on.
Alright. Let me start. So I prepared a
couple of slides to
guide us through
the theoretical part of it, and then
let's do
some hands on demo.
Let's do
where's that button?
It's there.
Helm Dashboard by Commodore. The name supposed to
be super obvious,
nothing fancy.
It's exactly
that. It's the dashboard that shows Helm
situation in your cluster.
My plan for today is to
introduce you to Helm if you don't know
what it is,
explain the problem, why we started doing that,
explain how we did how we solved that
problem, do the live demo. If there are
any questions, let's do
answers
let let's do an answer those questions hopefully
with also live demo. This is what I
like and prefer to do to answer the
questions by demonstrating the answers, not prioritizing
on it.
First thing is let's remember
what is this theme Commodore or Helm.
And Helm is actually a cool thing, and
it's a package manager.
Usually, people describe Helm as reverse. They say
that it's templating first. No. No. Its first
role, I would say the most important role,
is package management for Kubernetes.
It's actually
a bit of shame on Kubernetes
to not have an out of the box
package manager because
in any infrastructure
level
technology
that appears in the recent days,
you see that the package manager inevitably
emerged from there.
And, for example, Golang ecosystem, which I like,
they started from having their own package manager
and providing it. And other ecosystems like PHP,
for for example, they
didn't have any package manager for a while,
and then the third party package manager appeared.
The same thing happens to Commodore
to Kubernetes, I'm sorry,
that the third party package manager had to
emerge because the ecosystem itself
didn't produce
a package manager didn't introduce a standard.
Maybe a good thing, in my opinion, there
should be more centralized approach to package applications
in Kubernetes,
and and you should not need a third
party for that.
That's the history,
and Helm appeared and became,
I would say, de facto standard of parameterizing
and packaging the applications.
The
how is it called? Kubernetes
templating
the default
Customize?
Customize. Yes. It it it appeared later,
but it appeared too late because Helm has
already conquered the
market,
the the mindshare of the market and became
the most popular
way to deploy the applications. If we look
into data, for example, among Commodore users, we
see that %
of our users use Helm.
They maybe use it in conjunction with other
technologies also, but they still use Helm.
And second role of Helm is a contemplating
language. It's a way to duplicate and parameterize
your complicated Kubernetes manifest into something that is
more manageable
because it's great to have these microservice
all
loosely coupled things, but you have to manage
them still as a holistic,
application.
And today, Helm provides
over 10,000
packages,
thousands of repositories,
and there is a single command line tool
to operate it.
In my opinion, it's good and bad because
it's too many different things packaged into that
CLI tool.
But
that's the standard. I cannot
question the fact that Helm is the most
popular
way to package applications.
And from that popularity, we have
the whole ecosystem
emerging
from the community with plug ins to Helm,
with applications, with their own vision of how
you manage Helm or how you alter the
way Helm's
Helm applications are deployed.
And it always starts great with the technology,
and problems come and troubles come when you
start really adopting and using it.
The problems that are happening with Helm, in
my opinion,
is
they all they all originate from simple
concepts
that are used in
really extensive fashion.
In Helm, you have really
small amount of concepts.
A release a revision
of that release,
manifests values,
everything is quite simple. But when you start
using it on a daily fashion with
multiple applications,
many,
different variants,
and you add namespaces on top of it,
multi cluster aspect on top of it, suddenly
you feel that this CLI
is cumbersome for you because it's hard to
operate
with these
simple concepts multiplied
by
number of your applications, clusters, and namespaces.
And
I when I speak about this problem, I
tend to
divide it into
into two
areas. One area is that because of the
Helm popularity,
there are a lot of new users coming
into this ecosystem, and they need,
some more visual and simplified ways to learn.
And if you only give them CLI, it
becomes really hard for new and less experienced
people to learn.
I know from my past from these open
source applications
when,
in the load testing area that the magic
of popularity
comes when you respect the new users and
you give them visual,
easy, really easy to digest ways to learn
your tool and your concepts.
The experienced users on the other end, they
also want some
some visual
presentation of the complicated things that they do
because this is their daily efficiency.
They already know all of these commands. It's
just so long to run these commands, and
I will demonstrate on the further slide
what it actually means to perform quite simple
operation and get answer to simple
question with Helm CLI.
And
some people start immediately thinking how does this
idea of visualizing Helm
plays in conjunction with automation and CICD.
And I should say this is out of
the scope for the project. The CICD and
automation is already okay with CLI.
It's meant to be used through CLI. It's
for machines.
It's great for machines to to operate with
CLI. So we are not aiming to interfere
with GitOps flow and
CICD
setups with this project. But we all know
that
when things are wrong and you need to
do
investigation through CLI, this is the when the
amount of your CLI calls snowballs.
And it's okay if your CLI results in
couple of lines of response.
But in
case of Helm, you have long, long
manifests of
Kubernetes objects produced as a result of these
commands,
huge JSONs, lists
of
revisions
and
charts.
And all of that is really hard to
manage, especially if you are under the stress
of a failure.
And this is where we want to help
to experienced users also.
This is your looking glass
at your helm that's supposed to speed up
your operations in case of troubles or just
investigation.
A funny story. When I started this project
and first thing I did when I made
it just to view only capabilities of it,
And we looked at our own staging cluster,
and we actually found a couple of Helm
charts that nobody knew that it's there.
And we started asking, who knows what's that
thing? Its age is
two years, and nobody touched it since then.
It's actually a dead thing. How could we
know it without
actually when it's exposed
into our face through the UI? It's even
easy to ignore it when you're in CLI.
So that's the story. That's the motivation
and the problem that we're trying to solve,
to make things that you have
with regard to your Helm visual for you
so it's easier to operate and easier to
learn and get introduced into this ecosystem.
This is that example.
So I even omitted couple of commands to
locate the Helm chart inside your chart, but
now let's say we found that we have
this Locky chart in the Locky namespace.
And then to understand what has changed if
you experiencing some problem and you want to
understand what has changed in the recent releases
of it, this is what you're left with.
You need to generate these YAMLs.
You need to store them into files, then
you need to call
diff on those files. And if you
generated the wrong revision, you want to roll
back,
your view to one more revision. You need
to repeat all of that. And finally, the
step number eight, you're doing rollback.
And you see how many commands are there?
And I'm not showing you the outputs of
the commands, and usually those outputs are lengthy.
So this is what we're trying to solve.
We want to give
the visual way to consume all of that
information that Helm presents to us and have
slightly easier way to manage your Helm cluster
your installations
of Helm
packaged applications in the cluster.
And this is our approach to it.
We generate we created this project which gives
you the web UI because the web is
the common
way to to provide UIs today.
And through that web UI, you can see
what is there, what are the Helm charts
installed, what's their
state, what's their history,
all of the aspects of those Helm charts.
You can have the change intelligence. This is
the most important thing, and this is this
the the feature that comes or puts into
all of its products
into main
platform on of managing Kubernetes.
What has changed? It's it's easy to get
the answer, and I will demonstrate today how
easy is that with Helm Dashboard to
get the answer to the question of what
has changed when certain feature,
the flag or value was introduced.
And also, can do some
mainstream operations.
You can roll back the revision. You can
uninstall chart. You can install it, and you
can reconfigure it. And all of that with
preview.
And one advanced feature that we
wanted to include on top of the
standard Helm functionality is the scanner integrations because
this is the thing that became
the fact of standard in the industry
to
to scan your
manifests
and Kubernetes objects for the problems. So this
is something that is a standard
for today's operations with Kubernetes,
and we integrated couple of code scanning or
manifest scanning tools into Helm Dashboard, but that's
an optional
integration that you don't have to use
if you don't want to.
And, of course, it's all open source,
free. There's no
nothing that I'm showing today is closed source
or anything like that. I I'm I'm the
open source guy. I'm only doing open source
games.
There are some existing solutions. Let's be fair.
And today, I had a really funny morning
because I woke up and then on LinkedIn,
in one of the posts of announcing this
project,
one of the guys asked me the question,
how does this compare to k nine s
support of Helm? And I was like,
does k nine s have Helm support? Did
I miss something?
And I went googling because I completely
missed that thing. And I went googling, and
I googled this, and I googled that, canine
s helm, helm canine s.
I found nothing.
And I was curious. I went to the
canine s website,
and I read through their docs. I searched
through their docs.
No mention of Helm. Then I opened K
nine s and I typed colon
Helm and it said there is Helm.
And I'm
like, wow. What's there? And it's it only
shows the list of installed charts
and the notes, the description of the chart,
which is probably the least important information in
the Helm chart. So it's there. The support
for the Helm in k nine s is
there. It's just well hidden. And this is
what I responded to the guy who asked
the question because this feature is extremely well
hidden.
That's how
how I react on that
at first.
And well, it's hard to compare k and
n s because the the functionality there is
really, really small.
There are applications
like Lens, Kubernetes dashboard,
Kube apps,
but the
their problem is that the Helm is not
a central thing. Usually, it's some something on
the side. It's
heavily
bloated with a lot of features. And in
my opinion, it's really hard if we look
at that problem of helping new users to
get into Helm. That's not the way, for
new users to get introduced into ecosystem. It's
too heavy. A lot of those require much
heavier processes of installing.
While I would say that the simple user
and even experienced user, they only need some
sugar
that you put on top of that Helm
CLI, which is great. And
here you go.
And
if we it's a popular question. How how
does this relate to Argo CD? Well, the
situation with Argo CD is actually much, much
more tricky because ArgoCD doesn't use Helm when
they deploy Helm applications.
They only generate
manifest, but then the the actual management
is not done by
Helm,
which leads to losing some really crucial information
about the history of the chart. It's hard
in Rawkode CD to find the diff between
couple of revisions of the past.
If you have that question,
what led to a trouble. RUCD is
more about
GitOps,
and it
assumes that you will have your Git history
to answer those questions.
But between the chart and your
Kubernetes,
there is this step of generating manifests. So
in my opinion, that's not always sufficient.
And applications like Prencher and Codefresh,
they attach the Helm functionality
to some bigger beast requiring you
to sign in, sign up, and
have this huge beast and find in small
corner of it your Helm functionality. In my
opinion, again, it's defocusing
if you are just sort of starting with
Helm.
So this is the key in my vision
of
the Helm Dashboard project.
The key is focus.
Let's have a dashboard that is a UI
over Helm.
It's focused on Helm. It's Helm native, if
you will,
and
it's easier for you to grasp the idea
of what's going on there.
So what we have at this stage of
the project,
and it's already there. We have the Golang
application with web front end. It all runs
locally on your computer. It uses your Kubernetes
context. It doesn't do any
fishy things with secrets
and access and sign ups. Nothing like that.
If you have Helm working locally, kubectl
working locally, that thing would also
work using that same communication and configuration.
It will recognize and respect your kubectl
config
files, so you will have your
clusters listed there.
All of the functionality that I mentioned
earlier and I will show later, it's there.
It's easy to install. It's made in a
form it's shipped in the form of Helm
plug in. So you install it and then
you run Helm Dashboard,
and it does the thing. It opens you
a browser tab with the application, and you
can start right away. I will demo that.
We have GitHub project. We have GitHub issues
and Slack chat in as a support channels.
So you can either live chat if you
prefer that or use GitHub issues if you
prefer that. I'm there,
and ready and happy to answer some of
your questions.
We already have some questions and even pull
requests,
submitted by people, which is quite exciting.
And we have energy and knowledge to improve
it further. I have my road map. I
partially
expressed it into GitHub issues. If you want
to contribute
something, there are a couple of simple issues
to fix
and
maybe
bigger features to contribute.
I'm open for that collaboration
with anyone who's interested in pushing this
cool initiative forward.
And with that,
I think let's
dive into
live demo area where we will see the
things
live and going. David,
any notes so far? Should I proceed, or
do we need to
make a pause? Maybe I spoke too much.
No. I think you've described the project very
well. I love all the context. I love
all the history. I love that you've really
nailed down to what the problem statement is
and how you think you can solve that
and
help people. So, like, I think that was
a really good overview, and I'm looking forward
now to actually seeing you use the product.
Let's let's take a look at it.
Okay. Great. So let's let me shut down
the previous
thing.
Let's say I'm starting
my next
session of Helm Dashboard. This is my favorite
part of all of these
webinars and podcasts is the live demonstration. So
the way to invoke it, I it it
assumes that I've already installed that. There is
installation instructions on the Helm
Dashboard project page. There is this command you
want to
install it.
And
Helm
Dashboard
is the command you you run to
invoke it, and it pops up automatically
the browser tab with your list of installed
charts.
On the left, you can see my clusters.
I can switch to GKE,
and I can switch this is my local
default cluster of Kubernetes kind.
So is that the context that you have
in your KubeConf? Yes. Yes. Exactly. This is
my KubeCon
KubeConf
KubeConfig
context.
So this is my JKE with
the charts installed there, and this is my
local kind cluster
with the chart installed there.
So
let's see what's the first thing we will
we will do. Let's uninstall the chart
or No.
No. No. Yeah. Let's delete stuff. Come on.
Let's be brief. We'll delete it. I think
that we should go through the flow of
the view
view capabilities
first because if I will delete the chart
that has history, what will we view? So
let's view. Let's see. I I have repaired
the history for met metrics server.
So I clicked on it, And you can
already see how much information is in front
of you
even here
without
invoking too many commands.
You get you get all of that information.
So all of this meta information about the
chart, it's okay. But this is this is
the valuable part on the left, for example.
You can see the history of your chart,
and you can immediately
see that, for example,
this was the downgrade
and that lasted
for three hours.
Then after three hours, I upgraded it and
it was lasting for fifty six minutes.
And and this is the perspective that we're
trying to put into Helm Dashboard that you
most of the time so you don't care
the absolute date of when the thing happened.
It was on twenty sixth or twenty seventh.
It's more important for how long did it
last. If it lived
short life, then probably something was going on
there. Somebody was reconfiguring it. If it was
lasting for
weeks or
days at least, then probably it was a
stable state,
and it's a candidate to roll back to
if you have problems.
And you can see that here, for example,
I rolled back and you can see the
the icon designating that it was a rollback
action. So you already start getting some more
information than
you get with bare Helm
command line
that you run.
Don't get me wrong. This thing runs Helm
under the hood. It just
mixes it with a lot of sugar
and presents you a nice
birthday cake as opposed to the sugar and
flour
separated.
So this is the this is the idea.
And from here, we can do either actions
or we can view different aspects of this
Helm chart that is installed. Let's view the
aspects of the Helm chart. First, we can
see the current
resources in the Kubernetes cluster. We can even
describe those resources
and see
the described view of those resources to spot,
I don't know, events or problems that are
running right now. And
this is the first view.
The second view is the manifest. This is
where you start digging into problems and you
your problems usually originate from manifest. But in
manifest, a lot of times you don't want
to just look through the manifest YAML.
It's quite tedious unless you know what you're
looking for. You rather would look for
the div. Nice. And for example, you may
see that I was introducing the wrong command
line and then rolling back. What was the
meaning of this rollback? I rolled back
to the working state from intentionally
non working state.
And if I just click here, you can
see what was that
upgrade of chart revision. It led
it resulted in
some annotations and it should also be resulting
in some image upgrades.
And you can see this is this was
my
malicious
option introduced here.
So this is this is cost you only
one click. What was this? What was that?
Why why this didn't upgrade or didn't didn't
downgrade?
This is because I reconfigured it. And this
one is obviously the installation, the first step.
When I was reconfiguring it, was it originating
from anything else
or just my actions? Then we can switch
into values
and see what was my,
let's switch user defined values only. This is
what I did. This is exactly my change.
And it becomes important if you collaborate and
multiple people do multiple changes to the cluster.
This is how you figure it out
in case you have questions to what was
the story of evolution of this
chart.
So this was the reconfiguration
that broke it. This was the rollback that
fixed it back.
And all of that with just mouse clicks.
Super easy. The notes, as I said, is
probably the least interesting
part of every chart.
Nevertheless,
it's there.
So this is the viewing capabilities.
And this is the place where we'll probably
look at the integration with scanners,
the code scanners. There's this button.
You can describe the resource and you can
also scan. So if I if you have
locally installed
Chekov
and Trivy or one of these
problem scanner, you can click on the button
and it would trigger
the check of that Kubernetes resource for you.
So you can review what Chekhov
thinks about this specific chart and Kubernetes resource,
and you can also know what Trivy thinks
about it.
And they look at it from different perspectives.
The reports are huge,
and you can review that. But this is
your access to this
normal today
question of do I have any troubles? Do
I have any high priority troubles here?
Criticals. Do I have criticals? No. There's only
one critical. Well, probably criticals and highs are
to fee to be fixed. Maybe I should
upgrade something or at least keep an eye
on it.
Let's go further. How do we reconfigure? There's
this button
that you can just click,
and it would reconfigure
your the application. For example, there is this
already
existing value.
I can, by the way, downgrade the app
from this screen. If I really want, I
can go back
to the previous version, like or I can
upgrade from the same view if I want,
if there is a newer version.
And what's important,
this is where we assemble together
different sources of the information about the chart,
and we allow you to
manage the upgrade, downgrade, or modification
process of the chart with everything you need
at your hand.
For example, if you don't know what is
the parameter
that would scale this thing up, you can
look it up here. This is your documentation
from the chart.
What's the name of my
replicas? Okay. This is the name. I can
just put it here and say replicas five.
Okay. Let's not kill my machine. Let's say
replicas two.
And down below, you will see how you
how my manifest changes. It will actually change
one parameter here. What if I downgrade
to very old
version?
You can actually review that there will be
some more changes than just image versions changing
if you do downgrade.
And everything happens,
you see this before
you do it. And this is super important
because
the the vicious cycle of doing a mistake
and reviewing resulting failure and doing a mistake
in in configuration again
And all of that, it's not good.
But Helm
offers you quite painful
CLI based process of reviewing these changes.
So we're just taking all of that experience
and
assembling it into a nice UI that allows
you to review
before
you install.
And it also allows you to scan for
problems before you install. If I click this
button,
then there this whole manifest will be run
through Chekhov scan and it and you will
see
what
Chekhov
offers you as list of the problems to
fix in your
in your manifest that you are about to
deploy into your Kubernetes cluster.
If you want to do something about it,
do something about it. If you just review
and accept, you just push the button confirm
and it would apply
to your
cluster.
It would apply to your cluster, the changes.
And you can review. This is our new
revision,
and you can see that the changes that
you were seeing in preview,
those were actually applying here.
And
I guess it it
it starts the second
replica right now for us. The values, did
we change anything? Yes. We we set two
replicas now.
All of that is quite
expected. And note,
now when we have downgraded,
it looks into repository and says,
don't you want to upgrade? You are actually
not at the latest.
And there is even a nice button to
check for a new version. By the way,
there's a trick. I know that today Commodore
has released a new version of its
agent. So now I can demonstrate you how
the check for new revision
for new version
works because it's
it only works once when it finds the
new version. I will I will show you
that. So what else can we do? We
can roll it back to the previous
revision or we can select the revision and
roll it back to something that was
that we considered great. No. This wasn't great,
and
I think this one
will be
alright.
Let's do a rollback.
When you do the rollback, it tells you
what will be changed again before you rollback.
And let's review. Let's see what are the
command line options. Command line options actually do
not change, but there are some defaults
that were introduced by the chart.
Okay. I accept it,
and I roll it back to the previous
state. It has created the new revision. This
is how Helm works. When you roll back,
it doesn't erase anything.
It just creates the new revision.
It marks it as rollback.
And finally, we can uninstall this chart, but
I will not uninstall it because it's beautiful
and it has so many revisions. I would
rather uninstall something that I value
slightly less, that I invested
some less resources and efforts. Let's do Grafana.
Grafana,
you are uninstalled.
Well, it's obvious. It tells you what
you will
erase from your cluster
and
confirm
there's no Grafana anymore.
And again, since it runs
actual Helm behind the scenes,
this is not something that can desync with
Helm
information.
It's always
in sync because it uses the the actual
Helm information
inside it. It's not a custom database or
whatever.
But
you usually start with no Helm charts if
you are a new user. Right? So what
do you do? You have this repository section
where you can actually see the
the repositories you have. You can add the
repository
and you can install.
Let's go to
Grafana,
and let's install Grafana.
This is the repository that I have added
for Grafana upfront.
And I just click install.
We get the familiar screen where we can
change Grafana
pipe.
And we can see if we want some
values. Let's do the same
replicas.
Cluster role.
This is the preview of what will happen.
Let's do
replicas one,
replicas
two again.
It will recalculate the diff for me and
all of that.
What else? We can do interesting
thing.
Let's do the Rawk not created.
False. You see how I don't know if
you live this life of Helm documentation.
How do I configure it here and there.
And it's so easy. It becomes
even for me,
I I spent less time playing with these
things and operating Kubernetes,
but it's so pleasant for me to simplify
the life and see this documentation
and edit this documentation and preview the changes.
So
let's go ahead. Let's install, and it should
install me the new Grafana. And now this
Grafana
awaits for
containers to be created and become available.
We can look at it.
It now
scaling replica set
to two.
So it knows what I asked it for,
and in a couple of minutes, it will
make it available. So now I can reconfigure
for for example, if I'm not
patient.
Let's
get back to creating.
By the way, you see each time you
update Grafana Helm chart, it regenerates
your admin password. This is
a finding for me, which is surprising because
I that's not what I wanted to find.
But now I know something about Grafana, one
one small piece. So it would add a
bunch of new objects into my cluster.
Let's do that,
and let's see
that everything works. Well, it cannot keep up
with the pace of my changes, but I'm
alright with that. And
as always, you get these navigation through revisions,
and it's so much different from what you
get from CLI. I don't know.
What else what else can we do here?
Let me see the scans,
the resources,
the manifest, the values,
the change
viewing,
And
I think it is. I promised you to
show how
now it thinks that I'm on latest and
this is actually one of the frequent change
frequent use cases
that we hear if you read the Kubernetes
Slack
community,
people come and they say, have my Helm
charts.
How do I easier
check for the new version to exist? And
is quite frequent use case. This is why
we added this button, check for new revision.
I know there is.
Now I can upgrade. So I don't need
to leave this screen
and leave this context to quickly check for
the new version to exist. And now I
can upgrade to this new version
and
go ahead and
it all
happens
without
losing the context because this is what important
in these complicated environments
when you have so many basic entities, but
they are all interconnected and there is historical
perspective. It's important to not lose the context
and be able to go back and easily
navigate. And this is what we provide with
Helm Dashboard. Much, much more easy navigation
through Helm concepts
while everything under the hood is %
Helm compatible and it's true Helm inside. So
we're not inventing something weird
and incompatible
with what we do.
And basically, this is it. This is my
demonstration.
So if you have any questions,
should I I'll be I'll be able demonstrate
you the answers if
if it's demonstrable
here.
Alright. Awesome. Thank you. I think,
you know, I don't have a lot of
questions because every time something in my head
popped up, you were moving right onto it
right afterwards. So it's like your demo just
gonna flow it really well. It introduced us
to all of the features of Helm Dashboard,
which I just think is a really pleasant
way to manage what is otherwise a very
not complicated,
but cumbersome It's tedious. Right? You know, it's
It's tedious. Yeah. Yeah. And I I I
love
is that you know, the wild feature here
is that comparing the previous revisions, comparing the
previous values.
Because those are the things that ruin my
day when I mess around with Helm charts.
It's like, oh, I didn't know it was
going to do that. And you know what?
See that Grafana one with the regenerated password?
I ran into that a few months ago
and it was infuriating.
And it took me ages to work out
what was actually going on.
So Yes. Here here you you will you
will see that suddenly the password has changed.
This is your problem.
Exactly. Yeah. Because the chart generates that every
time you run it and it's, yeah, very
frustrating. And that you only find that out
when you when you go off the kind
of the standard path near using Helm template
and other things. But, yeah, that could def
with previous for the manifest and the values.
It's a very, very cool resource. Something I
wish that I had had in the past.
Awesome feature.
The one thing that
you haven't answered that I'm curious of how
Helm Dashboard handles that or supports that or
whether it doesn't is Helm Hooks.
Is there any integration to show me what's
gonna happen with the Hooks when I do
a Helm deploy?
I haven't got to this aspect of Helm
yet, and
I will
review that in the future. I I saw
that the Helm hooks it
it's not really
used too
widely,
and this is why I prioritize it later.
And I tried to implement the other features
that I believe the more mainstream features first.
But it's
for me,
it's interesting to sort out even these edge
cases because I want the advanced users to
also benefit from this project and from this
functionality
and not only the very basic users.
Awesome. So that's definitely planned.
Another
potential feature for the future, not right now
because it's still very early, but
charts that
there's the new feature with Helm that allows
people to annotate the values dot YAML with
schema information.
And I like when I see
if you can go back to the values
bit.
Yes. Sure.
Yeah. From, like, here, it would be really
cool if you were able to process that
schema information and make it a bit more
of a rich editing experience. I think that
Do you do you mean the these comments
or it's something even more than that? Yeah.
The let me see if I can find
you a quick example.
While I did that, if anyone in the
audience has any questions or just wants to
say thank you or awesome in the comments
for the demo, please feel free to do
that now.
Well, I
very quickly try and find something that has
it. Let's see. I
came across this recently.
Well, it's if it's something standardized,
cool, and useful,
I'll definitely
as I see, if if there is the
schema for this thing,
then I would love to,
on the fly, apply it to these values
and warn you that you misconfiguring
it, even before you do that. Yeah. Let
me So if I got the idea, then
it will be okay. Let me I'll share
my screen for just a second. Sure. Sure.
Go ahead. Well, can you see?
Yeah.
So this is the so the bitnami charts,
I think, are quite good for doing the
schema thing. But you can click on this
value schema here,
and it actually tells you the types that
you should expect.
Mhmm. So here, we got string. Here, got
an object, which then, you know, got
properties and stuff. So this information is available.
And if I remember correctly, it's it's really
horrible and that is comments within the YAML.
But then, I guess, what else are they
gonna do?
But if we jump to
I can never remember how you got to
the the source code from the artifact hub.
It's
actually in the Helm itself, it's quite
inconvenient
to get to the original chart of
that produced some
release.
And I'm quite surprised that they didn't introduce
any kind of unique IDs
to interconnect
in a reliable way.
It's all name based,
but it is what it is. If we
all remember the history,
it was a hackathon project
that started Helm.
So
Yeah.
So and our values dot YAML, we have
all of these comments which have
parameter information, which then ties up with this
schema JSON schema document that we have here.
So there's a whole bunch of information there
that it would be awesome to get into
Helm Dashboard and really annotate and augment what
you already have with, like, this rich interface.
I think that would be awesome.
So there's my feature. That sounds interesting.
That sounds usually, I I should warn you.
One thing that I really want to avoid
is to turn in turn this Helm Dashboard,
which feels lightweight and easy,
into a piece that will be, like,
really heavy
over overflowing
with these features. So Yeah.
That's my mindset at this moment because I
see there are alternatives with a lot of
functionalities
super,
super rich, but the
the dark side of it is that it
becomes
really
hard to navigate and heavy to operate,
and I don't want that. I want really
to speed up the process of operating
for people. But if it helps if if
your idea helps the process, I I will
review it. And if it helps the process,
we'll definitely do that.
Alright. Or somebody will contribute it.
It's an open source
for sure.
Alright. Awesome. Well, what I'll say is I
love what I've seen.
The levers
straight up value to people that are deploying
Helm Trust to the cluster. Again, that ability
to see the revisions,
how the templates have been modified, and how
my user and the value has made and
really highlight what those changes are, I think
makes operating and working with Helm and our
production like environment
using the dashboard a fantastic experience. So I'll
say kudos.
Really cool project. Hope most people take advantage
of it. I hope people get involved and
contribute open issues, pull requests, all of the
above.
So the
it's under GitHub.com.
Is it /Commodore?
Sorry. I wasn't pinned. Yes. It's
Commodorei0/Helm
Dashboard.
If you will Google
Helm Dashboard Commodore,
three words, then it will distinguish
this project for you from
some other parts of the Kubernetes and dashboard
universe.
Hound Dashboard by Commodore, this this is what
you need to remember.
Awesome.
Then I'll finish up with one last question,
and then I'll let you get back to
your day. Like, you said at the start,
you you have a road map. You've got
a a bunch of ideas that you you
kinda wanna work on. Do wanna share a
little bit of details about maybe what's your
your top priority? What's coming next? What people
should expect?
Let me see the it's easy to read
from the list of written written things.
Well, there is there
are a couple of items that are really
tough.
And to impress you, I can mention these
tough items. For example, this Argo CD problem
that
so many people use Argo CD and they
use Helm
deployments for that, but Argo CD doesn't
use Helm, so there's no meta information
in secrets where Helm stores it. So Helm
doesn't see these charts.
The question is, can we
somehow still traverse
through objects in or query
Kubernetes
for some labels and annotation and still show
these objects to people. So they if they
are looking for that information about Helm charts,
they will get at least something,
at least some view to,
their
by fact, it's a Helm originating
thing, just Argo CD does it differently. So
that's one hard item on the road map
to find what can we do and how
can we still visualize those charts for people.
Another problem that
that we have is
we need to integrate with more
artifact or manifest scanners
because I know that different people prefer different
kinds of
scanning for manifests, so we should provide more
variants of scanning
the the resources.
There is the advanced case of umbrella chart
that we now only display the first level
of umbrella chart, and there is the
heavy advanced case of
multiple charts
dependent on each other. So we need to
review that.
And I think we will get to those
advanced
questions
as
soon as we
fix first layer of feature requests that are
already coming people coming with these really cool
and practical
feature requests. And I will always prioritize
users'
feature requests, really makes sense and comes from
the field and from the community over some
of my theoretical
ideas that I would love to do.
And, again, that's the mindset of
open source veteran, if you will.
Awesome.
Well, all of that sounds good. Like, I
think all of that sounds great. Let me
fix my own language. Yeah.
You're right about the Argo CD thing. I
bet you could hook in to the Argo
custom resources and get enough information there. I
think that's gonna be a fun but challenging
thing to do. So I'm excited to see
how you look into that. And, again, give
people a single pane of glass for all
of their Helm Dashboard. I think that'll be
yeah. But like you said, it's gonna be
a hard problem to solve, but a useful
one for people, especially as has got so
much
interest and adoption across it. And I wonder
if that would even help with the Helm
resource as well. Although, I can't remember
uses I I already got one of the
issues from that Flux user, and I see
that Flux
did something
nonstandard
to the Helm the way they operated,
and there is an issue. And we have
it's actually a really nice discussion. You can
go and read it,
and you will see that we we have
some idea
how to
work around the problem
as a quick win,
and it's still open question how to solve
that or if it if it's even solvable
on the general level.
Well,
thank you for taking the time to join
me today for working on Helm Dashboard for
showing people how to make their lives easier
and for all the future work that you're
about to accomplish to make it even better
across all of this. Let's face it. Cloud
native is this. We have so many different
systems, so many different ways to do this
thing. You're working on a very noble cause.
Well, thank you for that. I would say,
please reach out to us again when you've
got any major updates to Helm Dashboard so
that we can show people how to get
started. And I encourage anyone watching this episode
to go check out the repository,
open issues, and get involved. So, Andre, thank
you again. Have a wonderful day. And do
you have any last words?
It
was a pleasure demoing to you. Thank you
very much, David, for inviting me. I'm I'm
excited to be connected to the community
and and share all of these applications.
Let's hope this is not last of our
projects and not last of our initiatives
because I I really love starting these open
source projects and letting them accessible to the
people and by that changing
and moving forward the ecosystem and the technology
world.
Cool. Let's all do open source and contribute
at least with your feedback.
Awesome. Thank you. Alright.
Everyone watching, remember to say thank you in
the comments. We'll see you all next time.
Thank you again, Andre. Everyone, have a wonderful
day. Thank you. Bye.